there is a new report it's an extremely
disturbing report which found that at
least eight republicans who were at the
january sixth rally
have been elected to office now these
are not
necessarily people who were
participating in the riot
um but these are folks who were at the
rally on january 6th huffington post
article
at least eight republicans who were
elected at the rally just got elected to
office and even more attendees of the
rally that turned into the riot will
likely be on the ballot in 2022
although most have claimed they didn't
breach the u.s capitol on that day all
were participants in the demonstration
leading up to the attack standing
alongside extremists to take part in the
finale of a months-long anti-democratic
campaign to falsely claim that then
president donald trump didn't really
lose 2020.
their victories on tuesday are a
possible sign of things to come huffpost
previously identified
57 state and local republican officials
who attended the rally many of whom will
be up for re-election and likely will
win next year
that these candidates enjoy the support
of the wider republican party and our
winning elections does not bode well for
american democracy that's an
understatement
showing that one of the country's major
political parties despite some initial
gestures that being horrified by the
events of january 6 is almost completely
unrepentant over its role in fomenting
the historic attack on the capital and
why wouldn't they there have barely been
consequences as i said before
um not only barely consequences
for the perpetrators many of their cases
still pending
um but no real consequences for the
insiders and some of them are getting
rewarded by getting elected
among the january 6th attendees who won
office on tuesday were two republicans
re-elected to the virginia house of
delegates dave larocque and john mcguire
um marie march a restaurant owner who
bragged about her attendance at the stop
the steel rally and who in a since
deleted facebook post warned of a coming
civil war in which she would be willing
to fight and die for both her family and
small businesses also won a seat in the
virginia house of delegates on tuesday
in city councils across the country
rally attendee natalie jangula won a
seat in nampa idaho christine eid who
didn't go into the capital
and later blamed the violence on antifa
won a seat in watchung new jersey
charles osberger
also won a seat on the town council of
mansfield connecticut susan soloway
organized transportation to the rally
won re-election to the hunterdon county
new jersey board of directors
in braintree massachusetts a former high
school teacher who resigned his position
after local activists sent a photo of
him outside the capitol
won a seat on the local school committee
it goes on and on and on
this is a really backwards time now just
an example of someone elected to give
you a sense of the caliber of these
people this is not someone but from the
rally this is just an example of a
republican that
um
voters liked enough to elect this is new
jersey truck driver edward durr
who was just elected a republican state
senator
and when he was asked well what are you
going to do
in trenton
he said i don't really know i don't i
have no idea this this is who is now in
a position of power take a look at this
chose to sit back and do nothing
ed what's the first thing you're going
to do when you get to the capitol in
trenton
uh i really don't know that's that's the
key factor i don't know what i don't
know so that is the key factor we'll
learn what i need to know
and i'm going to
guarantee you one thing yeah i will be
the voice and people will hear me
because if there's one thing people will
learn about me i got a big mouth and i
don't shut up when i want to be heard
i'm going to be heard
this is not
a lot the [ __ ] the host is laughing
this is horrifying guys
i will let
go ahead go ahead no you go ahead finish
your thought oh my god i was just going
to say that i i will be that voice for
the people because i chose to sit back
oh man
um
i wasn't kidding yesterday with my 2030
rant and the rant sort of was
this week's elections might set the tone
for some major republican wins in 2022
which could include taking control back
of the house and senate
i've already said 2024 with biden or
harris as the democratic nominees
it's looking dubious to me
you could see
um
republicans take the house and senate in
22
and the white house in 24 and then in 26
democrats are really going to be up
against the wall and republicans will
have continued damaging the environment
in the country it could be a very tough
eight to ten years for this country and
again i said this on a stream there are
some people who are mad and some people
who agreed
in many blue states things are going to
be fine this is not blue state elitism
and me saying i don't have to worry
because i live in blue states it's an
empirical reality that if you look at
the human development index of
massachusetts it's the same as norway
quality of life is like norway
connecticut has the hdi ranking of
switzerland
minnesota
new hampshire connecticut
they have the human development index
ranking of germany and hong kong
new york is equivalent to australia and
the netherlands
in lots of those places many things are
going to be mostly fine
but stuff like pollution and so many
others that cross state lines are going
to be really bad everywhere and
i still care about people in red states
do that have the equivalent you know
standard of living of of much poorer
countries so could be ugly for a long
time and um
the last 96 hours aren't pointing in a
great direction make sure you're
following us on instagram at david
pakman show we'll be back right after
this short break
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on
2 blinkist takes long episodes of
popular podcasts and distills them into
audio you can listen to in 15 minutes
with blinkist you can become
knowledgeable about so many different
things you can have conversations with
people about more topics blinkist makes
you more well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below